this is a
an incredible story okay this is from
the daily wire again it says cook county
state's um state's attorney kim fox's
office refused this uh
in chicago
refused to charge five men arrested in
connection with a gang-related gun fight
that left at least one person dead and
two wounded even though police requested
a number of felony charges for each
individual suspect because the five men
were mutual combatants
the five men were released leaving
chicago officials including mayor lawyer
light lori lightfoot incensed
the chicago sun times reported that the
men
linked to a deadly gang-related shootout
friday in austin were released from
custody after prosecutors declined to
charge each of them with a pair of
felonies including first-degree murder
even though police sought to charge all
five suspects with murder and aggravated
battery
um the outlet noted that the brazen
mid-morning gun fight which left one
shooter dead in two suspects would
extend from an internal dispute
between two factions of the four corner
hustler street gang according to an
internal police report and a law
enforcement source with knowledge of
investigation so
uh to review here
this is a gun fight middle of the day
somebody dies
they arrest
the survivors of the gunfight
and then prosecutors say yeah you know
what
all right
we're gonna let this one slide
not even a slap on the wrist here
not even not even give them like a
ticket for for being a public nuisance
um all five suspects were released
without charges on sunday because
according to the state's attorney's
office
listen to this
here's the reason why they're not being
charged
because according to the state's
attorney's office they were targeting
each other
so no harm no foul i mean somebody died
but no harm no foul
a spokeswoman first claimed that
prosecutors had determined that the
evidence was insufficient to meet our
burden of proof to approve felony
charges
even though these guys were out in the
open
shooting at each other but there's not
enough evidence that it happened
but they didn't specify what evidence
might be necessary to bring charges um
that the police department felt were
warranted
uh later they noted that mutual
combatants was mutual combatants was
cited as the reason for the rejection
a designation the sun times noted refers
to a fight or struggle that two parties
willingly engage in
uh the cook county prosecutor released
another individual from custody last
week for the same reason despite
indications that they were engaging in
gang violence
uh
um you know i i keep scrolling down here
to see the the punch line if there's
something else but that's that's it
they're saying
both both sides agreed to engage
in this gun fight and they were only
shooting at each other
and so we're not going to charge them
with a crime
this is
the chicago attorney's office
basically what they've done here is they
have in one fell swoop they have
decriminalized gang violence as long as
it's between each other
so if you're a member of one gang and
someone's on your your corner there
selling drugs you can go up and shoot
them
as as long as you keep it
you know within that as long as you you
keep it within
[Music]
as long as it's inter-gang violence you
don't involve anybody else
this you know it's bad when when even
mayor lori lightfoot who is herself
a deranged leftist far left
radical lunatic
even she is ticked off about this
because she at least has the sense to
see that this is
you're ushering in total chaos is what
you're doing here
you are now abandoning our city to chaos
that's what's happening
um
in fact that's what she said uh she said
if they do not feel like the criminal
justice system is going to hold them
accountable talking about
violent criminals gang members we're
going to see a level of brazenness that
will send this city into chaos
and we cannot let that happen
it's hard to imagine that it could get
more brazen or more chaotic in a place
like chicago
but that's what that's what they're
looking at
this is so so what i guess dueling is is
can can we have duals now is that back
on the table
has chicago just legalized dueling
so if you have a
beef with another guy you can agree to
meet out at high noon out in the street
shoot at each other
of course
mayor lightfoot has no room to complain
this is the inevitable result of running
these cities according to leftist
policies and philosophies
because what really lies at the root of
it whatever excuse they give kim fox
gives for not filing any charges the
real reason she's not filing charges
is because she just fundamentally
doesn't believe
that it's their fault
she thinks that they're all they're all
victims
you know they're victims of um
of systemic racism
you know this is this is not this is not
anything they're doing of their own free
will and volition
so you can't blame them for they're all
victims
a violent criminal who goes out in
chicago and kills someone else is
himself a victim as well
that's the mentality that laurie
lightfoot
subscribes to
all these democrats running all the
cities
believe that as well
so kim fox is really just taking it to
its logical conclusion
which is to embrace anarchy and chaos
and to basically abolish the law
completely well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content